[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Billy and I'm
here to talk to you today about making
art with virtual reality
so before I start a bit about myself I
work in San Francisco at a company
called open door we buy renovate and
sell homes and more than a dozen cities
across the country I personally work on
tools for operators who inspect our
homes and renovate them so please come
say hi if you'd like to chat with me
about it in my free time I help organize
a monthly meetup called waffle Jas it's
a series of 10-minute lightning talks
with musical interludes in karaoke and
yeah we just celebrated a three-year
anniversary so I'm pretty happy about
that and this is our handle on this my
handle on Twitter where I'll be tweeting
out a link to my slides and demo later
today and now that you know a little bit
about me
let's start to talk about the buzzy
thing of the moment virtual reality so
when I think of virtual reality I find a
bit overwhelming so like at least in
terms of the harder choices there's such
a wide gamut of things right on the
lowest end you have the phone in a box
model where you put your phone in a
Google cardboard Google daydream and
kind of play around with it and at the
highest then you had things like the HTC
vive or oculus rift where you have
entire you have hardware just to support
the headset as well as positional
trackers to show you where you are in
the room as well as trackers for your
hands as well on the software side
there's a lot of excitement as well
there are very games with PlayStation
there are 360 videos on YouTube and
Facebook has a social media thing that
they're working on but none of these
really hit the mark for me they don't
really make me think wow I really need
to get a headset for me what's missing
from the conversation is it's a
potential for making art most of the
mediums of work of art that we interact
with day to day have a lot of inherent
restrictions so there is only one given
what I would get been painting you kind
of Finley replicate it or easily remix
it for music and videos you can
infinitely duplicate them but it's
ultimately a one-way street
you can't meaningful
interact with them for videogames you
can interact with them but he can't
meaningfully change them as you interact
with them you're always playing within
the confines of the game with VR we've
reached a paradigm shift just like music
films and video games is infinitely
replicable just like video games it's
interactive
but with VR there's a large opportunity
for play and exploration especially with
the ability to remix other people's work
because VR is still in its relative
infancy we have the opportunity to make
interesting things so to demo the
potential of VR as a medium for art I
like to recreate an installation piece
by Yokohama called
obliteration room Yayoi Kusama is a
Japanese artist born in 1929 she's known
for her large-scale sculptures and
installation pieces so her signature
motif is polka dots on the left-hand
side you'll see a bunch of trees covered
in vinyl with polka dot patterns on them
and this is in Singapore in the center
you'll see a pair of heels with flowers
coming out of them that's at San Cisco
Airport and on the right hand side you
have bunch of mannequins covered in
polka dots and wigs and this is at the
Mattress Factory in Pittsburgh now if
you've been on Instagram you've seen her
work her most photographed pieces called
infinity room and it's a room where
there are mirrors on all four sides with
lights danglin off the ceiling so it
feels like you're kind of suspended in
space which is an interesting sensation
the piece I like to recreate is called
obliteration room it's an OLE I trim
white walls white floors white furniture
and visitors are given packs of colorful
circular stickers and are invited to
stick them all over the room I wanted to
recreate this piece because it's so
radically different with most art pieces
and most museums there's a dividing line
between the artists and the viewer the
viewer is physically separated from the
piece with glass and velvet ropes and
the viewer is mentally separated by
having to know a lot about the artist
the piece itself and the historical
context in which it was created to truly
understand it even if the viewer is
allowed to physically interact with the
artwork like a public statue for
instance it's not meaningfully changed
as a result
obliteration room breaks on the barrier
between the artists and the viewer not
only can the viewer phase
interact with the peace the peace
meaningfully changes as a result the
line between the viewer and the artist
become blurred I also found this so
striking because when was the last time
that you saw both parents and children
having fun in the museum together this
piece is truly meant for everyone the
young the old the highbrow patron as
well as the everyday person this what I
meant by us reaching a paradigm shift
with VR it's not like music or films
where it's infinitely replicable but non
interactive nor is it like video games
where it's interactive but not
meaningfully changed through our
interaction it's like all these things
and more it's a new medium for us to
play with as I thought about recreating
the obliteration room I wanted to make
it more personal to me I want to
recreate parts of my apartment for the
scene so instead of having to pay to go
to a museum to interact with an art
piece anyone could come into my
apartment and put stickers everywhere so
you know the thought of making art more
accessible to a larger group of people
made it really exciting to me so you
recreate this piece we're going to use a
framework called a frame first we'll
create a all-white scene with white
furniture then we'll create stickers on
the fly in the scene then we'll be
adding an interaction and physics to the
scene to make the stickers fly around
and stick to things a frame is a web VR
framework called created by Mozilla it's
built on top of three j/s which is a
WebGL library it's easy to set up and
has semantics syntax you can declare a
box in HTML like so and it'll render a
box like so and you're seeing pretty
simple it's really powerful too so you
can use it to create hypnotic visualized
visualizations like this which kind of
looks like a 60s music video and you can
create interactive games like this where
for some reason you're shooting a bunch
of smiley faces that are flying around
in space it supports the full range of
devices from the phone in a box model
like Google cardboard or Google daydream
to dedicated devices like HTC vive or
oculus rift with positional trackers so
let's get started we'll first create the
scene for us to put our walls and
furniture into
we can start by setting up a scene by
declaring a scene at the top so you'll
notice here I'm using pug instead of
regular HTML and we'll be declaring a
scene at the top over here then we'll
create the floor by declaring a plane
and the four surrounding walls and the
dividing wall with a box now that we've
set up the structure of the room let's
start to add in some furniture for this
demo we can use Google poly Google poly
is a library of 3d models and you can
download existing ones and remix them or
it can create complete and you want
yourself and upload them so you can find
single models like this which is a snake
that kind of looks like a poop emoji
just fun we can find more complex ones
like this one where it's a composite of
many models so you have a tent
bunch of trees a campfire sleeping bag a
lot of things going on in this one for
these 3d models and whenever you
download them you'll notice that you
actually get two files instead of one
one is the object file which represents
the skeleton the model which is the
physical shape of the thing and the
other one is the material files which
represents the skin of the model as in
the materials and the colors of the
thing in this example one dining set is
rendered with both the object file and
the material file and the other one is
rendered with just the object file so
you can see here that the one where it
with that's rendered with just the
object file it's pure white which is
what we want and since that's what we
want we'll just be rendering all our
models with just the object file instead
of both the object file and the material
file to load these files into our scene
will first need to use a frames asset
management system for a better
performance a frame pre loads and caches
3d models before rendering this is to
prevent things from popping in as the
scene renders with the asset management
system we can store things like 3d
models images audio video and genetic
mixings so let's try to load some of our
furniture that we downloaded at the top
we'll be declaring
a assets and for each of the objects
that we want to load in will be
declaring a asset item and then for each
item giving a unique ID that we'll be
using later on in the scene to reference
it and later on the file we declaring a
entity so a n today it's kind of a
generic container for things so it's
kind of like the div for a frame so for
each instance of a entity we'll be
loading in a object model file that we
declare using the unique ID that we
declared earlier one so as we load
object into our system sometimes they'll
be way too baked or weak too small and I
don't know about you but I personally
find it really hard to reason about 3d
spaces on a 2d screen and a frames
debugging interface helps with this a
lot it gives you a visual debugger to
play around with your values so you can
try things like scaling things up and
down moving things around just get the
right placement for it it's kind of like
the building interface in the sims where
you're you know putting your inner walls
your floors and buying furniture and and
things like that as you look through the
Google poly library you might not be
able to find exactly what you want so in
my case I was looking for a coffee table
like this in my apartment and this is an
opportunity for us to create a model of
our own using primitives so as you can
see the coffee table can be broken down
into a cylinder for the surface and then
for box elements for the legs so it can
write code like this to create a coffee
table out of primitives so first
declaring a cylinder to create the
surface and then adding in boxes for the
legs and then wrapping in a single a
entity tag to just just to make it very
clear that this is just one thing so
here's how it looks like in the demo so
you can see that because we created
ourselves it ourselves using primitives
you can kind of play around with it more
in the debugging interface so if you
don't feel like the leg placement is
quite right or the surface could be a
little bigger or smaller you can just
get a feel for it in the debug interface
instead of having to you know change
numbers and refresh constantly
we can do the same thing for other bits
of furniture too I wanted to put it in a
console like this but I couldn't find a
Google Pali so I tried to make it myself
so using a box element and then some a
cylinder elements for the legs now this
one it didn't turn out quite like the
other one we didn't try out quite well
so I think well I'll try to make it
better than this next version so so far
we've built our important apartment
moved in and arranged our furniture and
you can see that it's a bit eerie and
hard to see because of the low contrast
it kind of reminds me of the white room
in 2001 Space Odyssey but in kind of a
bad way so to make this better let's try
to add in some lighting if frame makes
it really easy to add lighting to a
scene there are five types of lighting
and a frame and we'll be using the light
types of ambient and point to build our
scene ambient lights affect all entities
in a scene an art depend on position so
you can use this to make sure that the
darkest shadow in your scene isn't
purely black but rather a dark grey this
helps to make the scene more realistic
since shadows or almost never pure black
in the real world point lights effect
entities all around them in all
directions and are dependent on position
this is useful to simulate things like
light bulbs which we'll be doing an ER
scene next I'll go briefly over the
three other lighting types so spotlights
they're kind of like point lights except
they don't light things up in all
directions they only point in one
direction like a spotlight or a bad bat
signal over here directional lights
simulate things like the Sun so it
shines in shines at a specific direction
but but it's a position agnostic so for
our scene here it would kind of make it
look a little too moody like Sin City so
that's not good and then how many street
lights or like ambulance except they let
you use that two different colors so
this might be useful for recreating the
hotline bling' video which might be fun
this is an example of how the lighting
API works in a frame you know it's
pretty simple so you can declare a type
here which are
ambient directional hemisphere respond
and for each type you can set color and
intensity and then for each lighting
type there are additional parameters I
can set as well so for point we can set
things like decay how quickly the light
should decay from the source and
distance how far the light should reach
in this example you'll notice that as
soon as you add lighting to any object
in the scene it turns out the default
lights so this means that we have to be
more intentional about where and how you
placed our lighting elements so to
figure out the exact coordinates and the
lighting options we can play around with
it in the debugger here we're playing
around with decay distance and intensity
to see what feels right for the scene
for a traditional lighting source that
you add to the scene it has real
performance implications this is because
the engine has to calculate how each of
the lighting sources interact with each
other as they overlap when I first put
together as this demo I had around 12
lighting sources which gave me around
well actually well below 20 fps and it
was pretty terrible so for the demo I
were to live down to three lighting
sources which keeps it well above 30fps
this is what the finished product looks
like with custom lighting there's higher
contrast so now you can actually see
that dining room said the TV and the
rest of your apartment instead of all
looking kind of eerie and low contrast
and kind of bizarre now that we've
played our place our lighting sources we
can start thinking about stickers first
how do we generate the stickers and
orient them in the correct direction
then how to throw them and get them to
stick on things for the sticker to do
seem like you're throwing it we need to
generate it where the user is to do so
we'll need to query the a camera element
for the position here's a code on how to
add a sticker to the scene it's pretty
simple so first you get the coordinates
of the camera then we generate a
cylinder of the appropriate size then we
set the position value to be where the
camera is positioned finally we appended
to the scene
can see here that as we respond a
sticker you'll notice the sticker is
always facing up it feel more natural
for the sticker to face you as you spawn
it and this means that we would need to
know the direction the camera is facing
this part is a bit more complicated than
grabbing the coordinates of camera as it
requires a bit more vector math as we
play around in the inspector we can see
that we want to rotate the sticker along
the x axis when you look up and down and
along the y axis as you look
side-to-side these rotations should be
set such in such a way that they're
always facing us when you call this
function you'll get back three numbers
that represent which direction you're
looking at in 3d space you can think of
x and z as the direction that you're
looking at side to side and y represents
whether you're looking up or down or
something in between
here's a diagram that might help explain
what's going on here so in this example
the camera is facing due north so when
you're facing to north
x is 0 that is 1 when south when you're
facing south x is 0 and that is negative
1 the issue here is that regardless of
whichever direction we're facing the
stickers are always spawning up where
the camera is located what we want is
two things
position position the sticker where the
camera is facing and rotate the sticker
in such a way that's facing the camera
we can do this by taking the inputs of
XYZ coordinates of the camera and its
direction we then use those numbers to
upload the correct X&Y rotations of the
stickers for me it's hard to think about
how to take three directional values and
output two rotational values to make
this simpler let's just consider the
case where the when the cameras
Direction is pointed at the northern
half of the scene which is when Zed is
greater than or equal to zero once we
sold it for that case we can just flip
the Y value for when Zed is lesser than
zero to get the mirror image this gets
us the correct rotation so in this
diagram you can see that the rotation
remains the same whether you're facing
due north or due south but when you're
facing North East the rotation is a
mirror image of when you're facing
southeast same thing for north west and
southwest
after playing around with the inspector
we can determine that the directional y
values of negative 1 and positive 1
should map to the x-axis rotation of 0
through negative 180 so to do this we
can create a linear scale with the
appropriate domain and range we do the
same thing for the x axis rotation which
takes in the directional X value when we
detect that the Z value of the cameras
to camera Direction is lesser than 0 we
just multiply the scaled value by
negative 1 to flip the sign so this
creates a mirror image in terms of the
rotation and after he makes the
calculation we set the rotation values
as a reminder this is how the stickers
used to spawn they would always face up
no matter where you are or which way
you're facing with the changes you can
see that the stickers are always facing
us no matter which way we face so so far
we've covered how to position the
sticker correctly and set the rotation
such that it always faces us next we'll
be figuring out how to launch the
sticker using a physics engine a frame
doesn't come with physics out of the box
so this means that it doesn't have
things like gravity collision events and
dynamic motion thankfully there's a
great package out there called a frame
physics system it's built on top of
Canon js' which is a WebGL physics
engine before it can get started with
adding motion to our scene we should
talk about the concept of bodies so
bodies are things that the physics
engine can interact with that surround
an entity in the frame physics there are
two kinds of bodies dynamic bodies and
Static bodies dynamic bodies moved
freely they have mass and react when
they collide with another object they
also fall if gravity's is enabled static
bodies are fixed or animate in a fixed
way so when they collide with other
objects the static bodies are unaffected
if reduce at the sofa is dynamic body
for example
so if ya fruit is that the the sofa is
dynamic body for example the stuff I'll
go flying is he put stickers on it and
so in this model you want our furniture
and walls to be static bodies and we
want and so when the sticker collides
with them they shouldn't move like like
this and we want our stickers to be some
blend of both we want the stickers to be
dynamic as they fly through the air but
when they had something they should
stick and remain stuck with this in mind
let's start putting in motion to the
scene as you did previously we need to
get the vector of the direction the
direction of the camera spacing so we
can launch the sticker in that direction
by directly setting the velocity on the
stickers body now keep in mind that we
do this after the physics body of the
element has loaded which happens after
the initial rendering so at this point
we've managed to generate stickers in
the correct position and launch them in
the direction that we're looking at
however we can see that the sticker is
simply just bouncing off the furniture
in walls instead of actually sticking to
them and this because the stickers
remain dynamic bodies after they collide
with the static body so to fix this
we'll be creating a collision event
listeners on these stickers when the
sticker collides with an object we can
check to see what it collided with if it
collided with the static body then we
know it's either the walls or the
furniture and that should it should
stick at that point we can have it
remain stationary by turning into a
static body so here you can see that as
soon as the sticker hits the static body
it turns into a static body itself so
that makes it stop moving and looks like
make it makes it look like it's sticking
to the sofa in the previous clip you'll
notice that the stickers don't stick
perfectly on the surface of the models
and this is because of how the physics
engine interprets models they don't
respect the curvature of the leaves of
this plan or the individual cushions on
the sofa and this is because the physics
engine interprets the models as
primitive shapes rather than the complex
models that they are this is to make the
engine more performant you can see how
the physics engine sees each of the
models to the debug mode so you can see
here that the
the engine sees the plant as a box
instead of the individual leaves or the
pot not a citizen now there's a slight
bug with the physics engine when you
create a custom non primitive entity and
then you rotate it the entity is rotated
but it's physics body is not so as you
can see here the physics body of the of
the doors orthogonal to its actual like
rendered thing so we can fix this by
mightily creating the desired physics
body first you can create a primitive
that most closely fits your model so for
the store we can create a box element
that's a static body and then place it
like so then you make it invisible and
then you're done you fake that physics
body and no one will be the wiser
I'd like to close out with a demo of
what the actual final part looks like
the demo is in it's obviously not a
perfect recreation of the obliteration
room but I think we managed to get
pretty far with the time that we had
now this quick demo we've covered a few
things generating a scene adding in
models and lighting dynamically
generating elements adding in a physics
engine and interaction and modifying
bodies now this should this barely
scratches the surface of what you can do
in VR some of my favorite VR pieces are
tilt brush paintings like this painting
of the countryside in Austria you can do
this you can see that this accomplishes
well you can't do with just regular
painting it's actually more like a
sculpture than a painting it really
conveys depth and has little details
that you couldn't do in a painting so
you can see under the water there that
there are fish swimming in the water and
you can see the underneath the boat and
inside the house and unlike a sculpture
though you can download it and endlessly
remix up to make your own then others
can download your work and remix it and
so on because it's digital isn't only
replicable because it's VR it can be
meaningfully interactive so I encourage
all of you to go out there and make
something at 360 video game a 360 video
a game an interesting tilt brush
painting or the simplest scene in a
frame VR is still uncharted territory
and everyone's soul just trying to
figure things out embrace the novelty of
it all
so thank you to everyone for coming to
my talk and thank you to jazz comp you
guys for having me and a special thank
you to
Vidia Nova sitting right there for
helping me a lot with this talk and you
can find the demo that I showed in this
role over here and this my handle on
Twitter where I'll be tweeting out a
link to my slice and there later today
thank you
[Applause]